bonsoir bonjour à la planète et si
stéphane parent en direct de montréal
dans le studio de tam-tam canada
l'émission qui vous amène qui vous fait
voyager à travers notre pays à travers
des causes importantes au travers des
dossiers importants de la vie
quotidienne des canadiens nous c'est les
choses de la vraie vie qui nous
intéresse et pour parler de ce soir est
vraie vie il faut le faire de façon très
simple vivante humaine avec toute
l'amitié du monde avec les collègues de
radio canada international qui viennent
de plusieurs sections
plusieurs équipes 1 de langue ici rci
alors on va vous allez voir on fait un
édit gestion de deux latinos américains
aujourd'hui
à commencer par ça crie le plus fort
paloma martinez bonjour et puis à léona
chapman qui est avec nous j'ai bien aimé
bonjour de la planète bonsoir la planète
et c'est beau l'amour bonjour bonsoir
stéphane en soi bonjour bon midi la nuit
et la nuit ou pousser le matin aussi il
dit bon matin ben yahia chantal
chandelle puisque nous parle de prendre
la parole pour poursuivre et bonjour la
planète
bonne nuit et bonne soirée bon
après-midi way et vous connaissez bien
sûr notre nouveau collègue de la section
arabe de paix nationale ça me samir ben
c'est samir ben donc bonjour la planète
bonjour collègues ici et bonjour les
filles hier c'était votre journée
internationale il ya aussi les vieilles
ficelles à 4 je pense exactement je sais
pas
maintenant allez on aura vous juillet 10
me cette semaine j'ai dit j'aimerais
beaucoup avoir à l'émission média au bon
d'accord c'est quoi le sujet j'ai dit
bien je peux pas te le dire
là j'ai vu qu'elle était un peu fâché un
peu contrarié ses nombreux contrats liés
jédir surprise j'ai pensé c'est quand
même assez bizarre elle n'a pas des
sujets moins c'est ce que tu as dit je
te le dirais pas alors ça va être une
surprise c'est quoi la surprise alors si
vous quel camp je faisais ma formation à
l'école supérieure de journalisme de
lille
on nous a dit toutes les improvisations
sont préparés la meilleure des
improvisations se prépare alors on
arrive dans une émission en profanant
n'a rien préparé du tout et il faut tout
improvisée préparée par super bien
préparés par mois - au mois lui il est
préparé on essaie ça dans ton prof de
journalisme va être content des noms est
la formule est bien connu il ya un
enseignant cinq élèves
ben nous sommes éternellement des élèves
alors dix étudiants même si notre way
carrière en tant qu'élèves et derrière
c'est un rapport de pouvoir quand même
donc si vous voulez oui alors paloma oui
vous lancer l'émission avec quoi
exactement pour devenir le sujet c'est
qu'est ce qu'on fait on va regarder des
images des images centaines d'imagés
cinq images
et puis on va dominer le sujet de
l'émission les sujets rap cette
intelligence alors on y va avec des
images oui oh c'est beau alors ça fait
déjà 10 ans a crié femmes tous vous
pensez nitoo c'est quoi c'est un certain
nombre qui menace aussi mohamed ancien
tricell asexuels environ sexuelle
commerce m
harcèlement ou c'est une année 2010 où
je pense que ça
photo voilà une année de mitu tout le
monde en parle moi j'ai commencé en pas
y penser avant tout le monde
j'ai découvert tout le monde en parlait
le saut prix mais on va quand même nous
avoir notre version
on va essayer de faire de l'analyse de
ce mouvement là de montrer ses limites
moi je suis toujours intéressé aux
limites parce que je pense qu'on est au
milieu de quelque chose on n'est pas ou
au sommet d'un iceberg
on est au milieu de quelque chose dans
le mouvement qui m'a transformé qui
transforme notre société jour aller plus
loin je rêve aller vers un
questionnement du dd sommes donc il y en
a deux huissiers démission
on est entouré de la majorité je ne
savais pas saluer marie-claude elle
s'occupait prend pas beaucoup de place
mais elle fait tout c'est la technique
celle responsable de la technique avec
pierre du côté de la technique sonore de
radio-canada à la distance leonardo
gimeno travail à distance aujourd'hui
pour s'assurer que l'on passe comme ça
partout autour de la planète
on a fini pour la cuisine de l'émission
je vais vous allez voir je vais vous pas
la vidéo numéro 2 non pas encore le
premier jeu de l'émission ça aussi les
honorables cinéma moi j'ai une grosse
boule de bingo on mettait les chefs
ayant procédé au tirage b un mythe ou
mais non c'est pas ça
non c'est un jeu qui revient l'émission
fut trois fois le jeu des grosses boules
à chaque édition de ce jeu vous gagnez
des points 20 points pour la première
manche 30 50 et ensuite on fait le bilan
et on détermine une grande gagnante ce
toujours une grande joie
j'ai pas mal souffert avec un nettoyage
maintenant c'est à toi samir voici la
question
qu'en pensent les québécois les
québécois on verra ce qu'on pense et
canadiens plus tard qu'en pensent les
québécois selon un sondage réalisé pour
le magazine l'actualité le magazine sans
doute le plus grand tirage et si au
québec dans la foulée du mouvement moi
aussi quel pourcentage des citoyens
croient dans l'ensemble les personnes
qui ont dénoncé depuis un an des
agressions et du harcèlement sexuel
allez on y croit quel pourcentage des
québécois disent oui ces femmes qui use
ses hommes qui viennent témoigner qu'ils
dénoncent on les croit
quel pourcentage des québécois parce que
ses victimes présumées victimes
74 ça va vite pour tricoter des
pourcentages ça déboule comme la grosse
boule 70 70 % de 53
le plus bas passé d'accord j'irai au
tour de 81,6 évoqué mais c'est vrai au
québec
je reste avec mon 53 bon alors c'est
encore une fois elle qui remporte elle
est le plus proche de la bonne réponse
90% dans une société où les gens se
sentent concernés par exemple aux autres
mais il ya un petit peu moins de
confiance par rapport à ceux qui font
des dénonciations uniquement en
utilisant les réseaux sociaux ça c'est
des choix sans ça vient de sortir cette
semaine n'est pas attentif au travail
c'est un chantage la compétition fait
parole de la compétition
seulement 57 % des québécois font
confiance au sol dénonciation qui sont
faites à partir des réseaux sociaux on a
moins confiance aux citrons peu facile
de les taper quelque chose à
l'ordinateur et de pas aller surtout que
n'importe qui pourrait le faire caché
derrière son clavier raconte alger
n'importe quoi non mais tu fais un
visage découvert quand même c'est ce nom
mais il y en a qui usurpe des identités
en qualité d histoire donc il ya
beaucoup de témoignages qui ont commencé
sur les voies nouvelles
je me dis que c'est ce qui motive la
retenue la part des gens qui se prononce
j'aimerais avoir une perspective d'être
un peu plus grande élargir au canada
j'ai besoin de bonnes perdu des gens qui
est peut-être dû porter du let dont vous
avez une bonne paire d'yeux ou pas comme
prévu perdu les eu à la fois vous aider
j'ai besoin quelqu'un qui a des bons
vieux qui a des bons vieux aussi
regarder la télévision
28 dans notre studio et regardez cette
vidéo numéro 2 de l'émission qui vous
donne un aperçu de la situation du
mouvement après ou dans les deux
premières semaines du mouvement il ya un
an
alors ça prend quelqu'un qui lit
rapidement ça c'est le premier tweet
envoyé
c'était le 15 octobre 2017 les tweets
par laquelle tout a commencé
d'accord ensuite 1,24 à 4.7 millions de
personnes à travers le monde ont utilisé
mythos le hashtag mythe ou sur facebook
et c'est pas fini la leçon se poursuit
au hashtag mythe ou 3 points et 1
million détruites à travers le monde
dans 105 milles au canada puis au total
171 personnes visées par des allégations
nature sexuelle aux états unis canada
royaume uni et france en deux semaines
seulement voici les grands chiffres les
grands autour pour les deux premières
semaines et donc c'était toute une fois
de la part du lion avec 104 jean-marc
c'est un domaine culturel que les
accusations d'un homme politique ensuite
en deuxième place voilà ensuite des
animateurs de radio comme un autre
en exerçant tous le pouvoir sur cette
question pouvoir dans les 100 points et
a fait pas la main vous avez vu dans un
sondage cette semaine vous avez fait
bondir dans cette question de relations
de pouvoir les 24 se trouvent les jeunes
femmes au canada
en fait c'est un sondage dont je fais
une nouvelle hier parce que ça m'a
beaucoup impressionné trois jeunes
canadiennes sur 3 sur 3 pendant
rapportent avoir au moins une amie
ailleurs vécu de l'harcèlement sexuel
donc deux canadiens sur trois défaites
entre 14 et 24 ans disent connaître au
moins une amie qui a été harcelé
sexuellement et donc on était à bout qui
ont été abusés physiquement ou
verbalement par des hommes
donc c'est quand même assez
impressionnant et moins de deux filles
sur 10 disent se sentir complètement
insécurité dans des espaces publics
c'est quand même c'est très bas donc des
coups de fil entre 14 et 24 ans et quand
même des chiffres assez excessif au
canada c'est grave comme situation
oui il ya un autre chiffre qui m'a
beaucoup marqué cette feuille sur 10
disent avoir été victimes de
discrimination par leur genre donc avoir
été discriminés pas sur dix sept sur dix
au képi y en a beaucoup d'entre elles
qui disent en fait y en a aussi qui
disent qu'ils se sentent à 1 égalité
avec les femmes mais d'autres qui disent
que l'argent peut affecter leur vie
professionnelle et leur vie pour être
personnel à long terme
donc c'est quand même là vous vous
copier vous copiez pas vous lisez les
informations vous avez déposé sur un
synode cette semaine oui un espagnol par
contre travailler pour l'équipe
espagnole que le la
le titre d'ea international de la ligne
donc si on cherche ça c'est sûr qu'on va
trouver l'information
mais ce qui était particulier 7,7 une
sondage pour le compte des planes
international canada un organisme de
bienfaisance au niveau international
puis ce qu'ils voulaient c'est défier un
peu la normalité de l'harcèlement sexuel
parce que les chiffres parlent
d'eux-mêmes donc on peut on peut
s'inquiéter de ce qu'ils disent que ces
jeunes femmes 10 mai donc ça devient
c'est anormal ce qu'ils disent c'est
anormal que les fait vivre cette réalité
la tendance à se demander si ça ça
arrive au canada
tout s'est passé imaginer sondages je
vais pas imaginer qu est ce que c
ailleurs ça pour les droits des femmes
des filles la conscience des mythes ou
et tout ça c'est quand même gros comme
le lac était en train de montrer ça
m'est tombé sur le plein quand même en
faisant cette recherche sur mitu et puis
moi aussi j'ai pensé comment ça se passe
ailleurs à auxerre de la france du
royaume uni du canada des états-unis moi
j'aime d'elie chiffre qui proviennent de
cette partie de l'occident
on va se tourner vers une spécialiste
qui s'appelle le roi chang qui est
professeur de philosophie à l'université
de montréal la voici bonjour madame
bonjour
écoutez vous êtes professeur de
philosophie donc vous intéressé depuis
longtemps aux études en perspective
féministe et on vous amène l émission
parce que vous allez essayer de nous
faire comprendre quel chemin on a
parcouru depuis un an
et qu'est ce qui reste à faire et quand
il reste à faire je pense qu'on aurait
besoin de très longues émissions mais je
me question pour vous pourquoi pour
lancer la conversation est ce qu a vu un
mot est ce qu a eu un mouvement mythe ou
ailleurs qu'au canada ou en france au
royaume-uni aux états-unis avez vous eu
connaissance de quelque chose
d'important
oui alors donc il ya eu un déferlement à
l'échelle internationale du mouvement
mikio mais à vrai dire en ce qui me
concerne je suis surtout consacrée à
suivre le mouvement aux états unis et au
canada
et au québec en particulier pour les
raisons de proximité aussi parce que je
crois quand même ma vie tous que les
mouvements nitoo aux états unis et au
canada ont peut-être pris un peu plus
d'envergure que ailleurs dans d'autres
pays ça veut pas dire que par exemple
mouvement en france n'a pas eu un impact
significatif mais je crois que vraiment
états unis et au québec canada
c'est très intéressant de suivre à quel
point le mouvement c'est vraiment
inscrit dans une culture comme dans une
culture collective
d'ailleurs les 7,6 que vous avez évoqué
donc le fait que par exemple les six
hommes au québec que 90 ans en quelque
90 pensions donc des québécois si j'ai
bien compris les résultats que vous
allez présenter
on a tendance à croire les témoignages
d'agressions sexuelles en dehors des
réseaux sociaux mais à visage découvert
comme sa mère est justement le lundi
comme si je crois que ça révèle
justement là comment dire l'intérêt
particulier que ce mouvement a
précédemment québec
est-ce que des différences entre la
réaction des citoyens de la société ici
au canada et aux états unis au niveau de
comment on gère ce oui j'ai quand même
l'impression qu'il ya aussi tout de même
des différences entre le mouvement
s'était uni et le mouvement canada dans
la maison j'ai très bien que le savoir
c'est des résultats de sondages
similaires auprès de la population
américaine pour voir si on atteindrait
le même tous deux comme en dire de même
90 ans mais si vous me permettez une
juste de revenir un peu court mais pour
dire une chose au sujet de l'origine de
mouvements de 8 ou alors je crois que
c'est très important en effet de
signaler que le 15 octobre 2010 c'est ça
fera un maintenant je le mouvement mais
tout après à partir des états unis à
cause de ce fameux hashtag qui a été
lancé par une actrice américaine assure
toiture mais c'est très important c'est
de ne pas perdre de vue qu'en vérité
l'expression de mitu vraiment la
maternité de cette expression est
tributaire de tarnos burke qui est une
activiste noire américaine qui déjà
partir de 2006 avait emprunté cette
formulation pour parler justement des
agressions sexuelles
dans la société américaine dans laquelle
elle essayait justement le combat se
fier aux alléchantes
oui madame chan ont parlé de réaction
tantôt il a une qui m'a particulièrement
étonné c'est la réaction de la première
dame des etats unis
madame mélanie à trompe par rapport à la
sphère tavana elle a estimé que la
victime n'avait pas suffisamment de
preuves
elle a parlé de manque et d'évidence
propofol évidence
donc je veux savoir en tant que
professeur de philosophie comment vous
percevez cette réaction là alors écouté
la narration est attendu entre 1 tant
d'égards que c'est très difficile
d'essayer d'expliquer de façon
rationnelle les réactions des secteurs
où seuls de satanistes rational mais et
c'est tout à fait tout à fait pertinent
de souligner le training excusez moi
l'expression mondiale mais les familles
incroyable de du premier anniversaire de
du mouvement bicloo en même temps que la
nomination extrêmement controversée
évidemment du juge kavanagh qui
maintenant est en effet juge de la cour
suprême aux états unis contre la parole
et le témoignage le professeur christine
betty ford qui nous rappelle aussi
évidemment une autre histoire quand même
assez assez déchirante et bouleversante
qui est celle de annick sa fille qui
était également professeur donc dans
bone estellise d'un aux états unis et
qui en est à 91 avaient également
activement dénoncer justement les
comportements d'harcèlement sexuel qui
avait subi la part de craintes thomas
qui lui aussi a ses sièges désormais
donc sur la conception malheur donc
force est de constater que le mouvement
ni tout comment dire me souvenais grands
traits une culture du viol qui reste est
venu en tant longtemps longtemps
longtemps que bourg une culture de
l'incrédulité une culture des rapports
de force et d abus de pouvoir qui
s'exprime de façon j'en ris à travers le
phénomène de harcèlement sexuel et c'est
de tout cela dont il est question à
travers le mouvement mis tout il ya
certains qui disent que le mouvement a
mis tous comment dire pas ce silence
certaines modalités racialisée où
certaines modalités du mouvement en
termes de classes société parce que
également le mouvement mais tout a été
popularisée à cause des actrices
hollywoodiennes et il faudrait surtout
pas perdre de vue que dans la vie
quotidienne c'est beaucoup moins
spectaculaire mais beaucoup plus
prégnant beaucoup plus tragique aussi le
phénomène des violences sexuelles est
tout un jeu samir vous prenez des notes
je vous vois aller vous avez des
questions mais je voulais faire le lien
avec le mouvement agression en ont
dénoncé au canada vous rappeler de ce
mouvement là est-ce qu'il ya pourquoi ce
mouvement n'a pas eu cette incidence n'a
pas fait ce tout tout ce tapage comme le
mouvement mamito je veux pas les
comparer mais je voulais juste savoir ce
que vous avez pris le temps d'étudier ce
mouvement-là qui était après laffaire
commission 2000 dans l'afflux de la
sphère jian ghomeshi et dans la foulée
de l'essor du mouvement demi tour je
crois tout de même que et au québec
comme au canada
je vais dire à cette dénonciation cette
condamnation la culture du viol et c'est
cet esprit un appel collectif à l écoute
les témoignages d'agressions sexuelles à
comines a quand même pris un certain
essor aucune allergie je crois pas que
c'est quelque chose qui est acquis et
que tu a sous-estimé et signe qu'il est
peut-être juste par exemple pour revenir
au contexte km c'est ce que j'espère
qu'ils d'un kid rares s'agira aussi de
tout ce mouvement c'est un éclairage et
un accompagnement beaucoup plus encore
plus vigilants et vos bourreaux auprès
par exemple des femmes autochtones qui
donc elle aussi parlent et dénonce et
condamne les agressions sexuelles dont
elle-même ont été victimes et je crois
que c'est maintenant ou jamais où le
gouvernement canadien la société
canadian city québécoise doit âgées
doivent justement à l'espagne dans cette
démarche
et ça veut dire aussi une accompagnement
politique pour notamment soutenir
justement le travail de l'enquêté
nationale sur les femmes des filles
autochtones disparues assassinées dans
la foulée de tous mouvements lâchera que
ici au canada hong hanh opportunité
incroyable pour saisir l'occasion pour
démontrer chez seulement la sécurité
politique à l'est
notamment des fermetures un parlement
puis ensuite chantal a fait je voudrais
juste commenté
concernant et ses alliés un peu avec le
cas des femmes autochtones disparues
disparues ou assassinées ici au canada
c'est le mouvement qui a commencé au
mexique puis ensuite en argentine plus
tard ennemi on amasse cht ni une hamas
c'est un mouvement qui a commencé dans
les années 90 verbe fin des années 90
début des années 2000 pour dénoncer la
mort des plus débat beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de femmes des centaines et des
centaines de femmes au nord du mexique
est aussi ailleurs dans l'amérique
latine des femmes qui disparaissent et
des femmes qui était tout seul qui
travaillait dans les maquiladoras au
nord de au nord du mexique près des
états unis et puis qui venait soit de
l'amérique centrale soit du sud du
mexique qui monte tout le chemin vers le
nord et puis qui qui qui ont été
beaucoup violente et beaucoup d'entre
elles violente et donc ces mouvements
mitu c'est un peu moi je le vois dans le
souci de l'amérique du nord et dans le
contexte de ce mouvement qui a commencé
bien bien avant on décrit sous le terme
de féminicide eu tout à fait raison de
leur hacker ait usé notamment à la
lumière des études de cas où la
problématique ou de l'ampleur de ce
phénomène dans la frontière états
unienne et il exclut notamment donc en
main de centrales et je profite de la
transition pour aussi du fait que on a
octroyé donc le prix nobel de la paix de
l'es18 à 2 2 acteurs 1 2 0 qui est
dénonce donc les violences sexuelles
dont les femmes sont victimes à la
concorde octobre des listes broyées
république démocratique congo qui a
dénoncé à travers sa pratique médicale
qui consiste essentiellement à essayer
de sauver les femmes victimes de
violences sexuelles en compte et se
confirmer deux mecs
évidemment les reliques est remarquable
mourad qui faisaient partie de ces 1
3000 femmes et ziti qui ont été
violentés par encore une fois donc les
acteurs 10 dh et c est encore une fois
et dans le contexte de ce prix nobel de
la paix évidemment c'est pas tout à fait
des choses c'est clair qu'il ya quand
même une résonance en écho entre
justement l'a longuement mis tout est de
fait que d'attirer l'attention mondiale
internationale seront des violences
sexuelles dont sont victimes les femmes
il n'y a pas que les femmes évidemment
qu'ils sont victimes de violences
sexuelles mais étant donné les
statistiques et le pourcentage victimes
de violences sexuelles qui sont très
largement des femmes on a raison de
parler de finissez dans une raison de
parler quand même de la dimension
extrêmement gens rient de discernement
devient en six mois j'ai passe aussi par
rapport à ce que parlement vient de dire
aussi j'étais surpris c'est comment ces
mouvements mis tout est en train de
prendre de l'ampleur partout dans le
monde
c'est devenu très politique très
politisée et on a vu ça au brésil la
semaine dernière avec les candidats
d'extrême droite qui oui c'est ça alors
il est comme il est très sexiste et il
est anti droits des femmes et il y à une
manifestation et dans les sondages il
est gagnant c'est l'extrême droite et
dont il ya eu la semaine dernière des
centaines de milliers juste des femmes
qui sont sortis dans les rues du brésil
pour protester contre sept candidats de
l'extrême droite
alors ces mouvements mis tout comme un
argentine au mexique et ailleurs ça
prend de l'ampleur et ça devient très
politisée j'entends c'est une question
oui au fond je sais pas si c'est une
question mais j'ai vu sur les réseaux
sociaux ces derniers jours l'image de
colomb occidentaux en afrique ces 10 ans
les femmes par le bout de leurs seins
des femmes totalement nu des femmes qui
ont été violées à cette époque là est un
viol qui a été passée sous silence
je veux savoir quel peut être l'intérêt
aujourd'hui de souligner de tels faits
est ce que on pourrait avoir une espèce
de résonance dans le monde aujourd'hui
quelle peut être l'importance de telles
images selon vous car c'est incroyable
comment il faut espérer alors il faut
espérer que mouvement me touche puis ce
ou ces à l'échelle internationale encore
une fois en convergence avec l'octroi et
le choix des plus bas de la paix 2010
est extra puisse justement vous
présentée l'opportunité de faire un vrai
mandat de de pouvoir faire des avancées
dans tant de domaines où justement les
femmes ont été victimes de sévices
sexuels alors vous faites référence à ce
cas là on peut faire référence aux
diffuseurs c'est vieux comme le monde
dont le fait que les femmes ont été
victimes de violence sexuelle comme arme
de guerre ou comme un mécanisme
d'oppression etc
alors donc il faut espérer comme vous le
savez qu'on puisse parler de cela de
façon beaucoup plus franche frontale est
explicite
après dans la foulée du mouvement du
tout mais vous savez on qu'il est aussi
un battle assure aux mouvements de mitu
à l'entente qu'il ya des formes de
mouvements qu'on pourrait qualifier de
masculine et ce en face à cesson du
mouvement qui se nomme film tout si j'ai
bien compris où c'est une sorte de
commandes besoin de joindre le président
tu investis seurs qui est extraordinaire
c'est que l'administration ne chante pas
quel point jeudi à rome
à quel point c'est une amie de façon
absolument car vers il vient légitimer
ce type de mouvement qui remettent en
cause les avancées un potentiel du
mouvement demi tout en essayant de
maintenant victimiser les avancées çà
c'est assez incroyable travers
l'alternance l'année manipulation
rhétorique et biologiques génie français
le professeur john on va regarder ce que
tout le monde a vu autour de la planète
la semaine dernière monsieur trump qui
rigolaient qui faisait des farces au
sujet du témoignage de cette dame qui
affirmait que le celui qui était en
nomination à la cour suprême
fait des choses exactement c'est dans ce
contexte-là qui l'a complètement
légitime ces discours qui a baissé de
2,2 c'est justement le moment on écoute
[Applaudissements]
c'est comme un stand up comique il ya eu
la réaction de l'ancien premier ministre
du canada jean chrétien qui l'a dit
simon premier ministe fait c'est dire et
ça aujourd'hui j'aurais honte
alors on voit la différence à sac et le
premier stress à qui on doit bien ça se
règle et déclarations évitons de régler
les problèmes des américains ils en ont
suffisamment d'accord mais ce message
envoyé par quelqu'un qui est en vie
quand même été entendus ici
pensez vous que les jeunes au canada
entendent quelque chose
j'ai tendance à faire confiance aux gens
j'ai tendance à faire confiance aux
forces progressistes des prochaines
générations en fait la génération des
millenium comment les appels etc
j'ai l'impression qu'ils portent en eux
un ras le bol à des certaines de
certaines forces réactionnaires qui ont
été portées peut-être par des
générations antérieures et j'ai j'ose
croire que les jeunes d'aujourd'hui qui
s'éduque politiquement et qui s'éduque
socialement et culturellement dans la
mouvance des mouvements comme mitu etc
j'ose croire qu'ils vont porter et qui
sont justement les forces motrices de
progrès social à venir je l'espère jeu
étant professeur j'ai l'impression de le
voir chez les étudiants qui chancelle
elles sont quand même de voir des
esprits qui sont beaucoup plus ouverts
que dans la recherche des solutions
parfois on néglige beaucoup les garçons
on parle beaucoup des flics ce qu'ils
subissent
mais je pense aussi que on les dit
souvent ici au canada c'est l'éducation
qui compte
il faut faire
l'éducation relation sexuelle dans les
écoles dans les écoles mais aussi viser
les garçons parce que ça c'est un
problème même s'il ya des avancements
c'est un problème qui ne finira jamais
dans les hommes sont partis de la suite
de la solution à la maison aussi c'est
pas juste la responsabilité de l'école
lecocq est paru et un autre enfant un
garçon je mets ça avec une grande
responsabilité d'un garçon de 15 ans
auquel et je dois m'adresser constamment
concernant ce qui arrive
concernant les nouvelles concernant le
mouvement est au courant à l'école on en
parle mais quand même le travail doit
être fait aussi à la main sans et puis
il ya jusqu'à hier j'avais cette
conversation avec lui on a discuté sur
les commentaires de monsieur terrab sur
les cadets madame ford sur le mythe ou
ici et ailleurs
donc c'est important d'avoir ces
conversations là c'est pas juste
l'écueil freinage et une anecdote m'a
monfils qui avait 9 ans il m'a dit que
c'était par rapport à la sphère rozon il
m'a dit qu'est ce qu'il a fait ce
monsieur
comment lui expliquer selon lui des
films et julie d'écouté il a il a essayé
d'embrasser une madame qui ne voulaient
pas donc c'était donc le pâton moisi
tous les fils et posez votre question
oui mais là me tient en fait moi j'ai
deux questions réflexion d'abord c'est
sûr qu'il faut en parler des agressions
sexuelles et de la violence sexuelle
il faut le mouvement mis tous qu'il faut
évidemment qu'il fasse ce qui porte ses
fruits mais ne trouvez vous pas qu'il ya
un petit peu trop d'attention médiatique
sur des cas spécifiques comme par
exemple madame la docteure foire est ce
qu'on avait vraiment d'antan besoin le
public mondial dans tant de chacune de
ces questions est ce que vous pensez que
c'est d'intérêt public pour vous parce
que c'est comme ça que ça s'est retourné
contre elle un peu c'est que maintenant
tout le monde dans sa cuisine peut
débattre si elle est coupable ou non
alors dans quelle mesure il moi je
trouve que peut-être la société à un
genre de fascination aussi pour ses cola
qui fait qu'ils sont surmédiatisés puis
qui nuisent à la victime
puis il semaine
deuxième réflexion c'est qu'on semble se
soucie beaucoup de l'homme est il
coupable mais est-ce qu'on se soucie de
la femme va t'elle mieux son est elle
sortie
comment se porte-t-elle selon s'est
jamais posé comme question mais on veut
toujours savoir est ce que est ce qu'il
a fait ce qu'il a fait ce qu'il a fait
ce qui l'a pas fait c'est l'obsession
pour être accueilli ainsi ce sont
d'excellentes questions commentaires
auxquels j'ai pas vraiment de réponse
définitive mais juste que je partage
avec vous la préoccupation que vous avez
c'est à dire le prix à payer pour ces
femmes qui osent aller sur la place
publique pour dénoncer des agressions
sexuelles dont elles ont été victimes
d'autant plus lorsqu'il s'agit de
figures publiques de cette notoriété va
comme les présidents trois épreuves
cabana et c'est le courage un que les
amitiés et les ford affiche est
incroyable parce que c'est comme vous
devez temps il ya quand même aussi je
crois que vous avez raison une forme de
voyeurisme un peu pervers autour de la
sur médiatisation de ces cas là c'était
c'est incroyable c'est inconcevable de
se mettre à la place de ces femmes là
mais force est de constater par contre
elle m elles rendent au prix de leur vie
et de leur vie privée et delà de la
libye est en faillite c'est au prix même
de leur sécurité même ses patientes est
incroyable ce type parce que à travers
leur cas et quand même cette
conversation là qui s'élargit qui prend
de l'ampleur à travers justement une
vente du professeur john on va terminer
avec cette question là elle est dure
elle est insensible mais elle est dans
les bouches de beaucoup de personnes des
hommes beaucoup d'hommes
j'entends cela beaucoup là est-ce qu'on
a encore besoin des cours de justice
l'affairé réglée devant les médias sur
les réseaux sociaux est ce qui a encore
une place pour les cours de justice et
où l'intégration des cours de justice
dans le mouvement mis tout c'est la
question alors l'état de droit et à d
autres l'état de droit j'y crois et je
pense que c'est en fait blanc le défi
est justement de rendre le processus de
faciliter le processus pour que
justement tout c'est tout c'est comment
dire
tous ces témoignages et toutes ces
dénonciations et tout et ils puissent se
faire entendre dans un cadre légal
dans un contexte état de droit ça c'est
clair
il va de soi que il faut faciliter ce
passage bien de la prise de parole vers
justement à la prise en compte dans le
système judiciaire
mais en fait ce qu'il faut aussi se
rendre compte c'est que bien que je
comprenne qu'elle et le comment dire
quelles sont les préoccupations derrière
des questions il faut aussi surtout
comprendre que le système judiciaire
jusqu'à nouvel ordre
justement a eu tendance à ne pas
entendre ces témoignages d'agressions
sexuelles et à des crises à
décrédibiliser en fait le témoignage des
victimes de violences sexuelles
et c'est justement à en raison des
failles du système judiciaire que que le
mouvement nous tous a dû remettre les
pendules à l'heure
en fait c'est ça qui m'a surpris le plus
de la déclaration de mme eliane amélien
mélanie à trump concernant l'épreuve
parce que quand on a été agressée
sexuellement ou harcelé sexuellement
c'est très difficile d'avoir une rue
comment tu peux prouver c'est la nature
même de phénomènes de faire ça un secret
à un cachette à un alliant de pouvoir
sur la personne qui subit le harcèlement
dont de quelle manière on peut amener
des preuves c'est ça qui est difficile
moi je vois dans toute cette histoire
c'est quand j'entends qu'il ya juste une
femme qui vient qui dit et il a fait
quelque chose quand il y en a plus
qu'une victime là je commence à me dire
il ya quelque chose qui se passe chez
moi un e
quand j'entends qu'à dix personnes qui
se plaignent jeudi malaga
je sais qu est-ce qui le sont c'est très
difficile de dire que c'est pas possible
à ce que yahya yahya comme une preuve
par le nombre suis pas à l'aise avec ça
mais elle est là pour moi elle est là
mais en même temps il ya des personnes
qui l'ont probablement fait dans des
circonstances que les femmes n'auraient
jamais pu se parler entre elles ou
savoir des déstockages attendons sans
quoi le crois que c'était juste
mais là on peut se connecter entre
citoyens c'est vrai en fait ce qui fait
le jeu pense l'originalité ce qui suit
peut parler ainsi du mouvement mis tout
ce que les femmes on voit elle perd la
peur de parler la laisse derrière elle
la peur même si ça existe encore des
plus en plus de femmes aux raconter leur
histoire et ça je trouve que c'est un
point important si je peux citer un
chiffre donc selon les données de la
sécurité publique en 2013 seulement 5 %
des agressions sexuelles étaient
véritablement sa présence et sa victoire
1-6 et tout à fait le contraire le
discours qui consiste à dire mais encore
une fois je reviens sur les questions
que les préoccupations dont vous faites
et qui sont parfaitement légitimes il
faut croire avec toi il faut il
améliorer mais je galope
en fait c'est le poste chez de serre qui
faillit un cours injustement rendre
compte des désagréments sexuelles dans
les femmes grande majorité de femmes
c'est à dire 65
on sent des victimes des agressions
sexuelles sont en fait des femmes et
c'est à leur détriment fait que le cmj
sert à ériger des obstacles sans nom
parcours sais pas je pense à 6 mg de sel
c'est vraiment une culture sociale
ce phénomène là de façon hockey
professeur chang mes collègues me disent
qu'ils veulent poursuivre le débat
malheureusement c'est pas possible parce
qu'il est question de temps après tout
donné mais ça se poursuit bien sûr c'est
pas fini une année puis en rond on
poursuit le combat tous ensemble pour
avoir une société plus juste plus
beaucoup plus que juste là égalitaire
plus équitable aussi ha bon côté station
oui comme disait le premier ministre
trudeau cge pierre paupières et le
trudeau mais là justin le fils à feu
après thoune et en 2015 2018 professeur
chang merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
l'invitation
mais hier c'était professeur ian lee
professeur de philosophie ni un style
morial le temps des boules comme la
grosse boule le jeu à la santé on a
quand même
on a quand même de la place pour le rire
ici c'est possible oui mais parce que
vous parlez de mary rose
rires bon c'est un cas mais non et puis
côté amusant
oui parce que dans les mouvements mais
me on peut descendre éclairage un peu je
joue pas beaucoup
voilà c'est fait je me levais la
prochaine fois y'a pas de problème je
pourrai plus parce que vous pouvez
peut-être fait toucher les fils et
filles enlevées les films du moment
pendant du plaisir d'accord alors toute
la planète connaît bien les expressions
les mots diez qui ont été utilisées des
maudits est très imagée pour dans ce
mouvement du du moins aussi du mythe ou
lequel de ces trois mots clics avec mon
diez du mouvement moi aussi n'existent
pas en réalité lequel les droits
n'existent pas en réalité
écoutez bien là a eu au québec hashtag
gros écran en italie hashtag qu'elle a
vot hachey ou en france hashtag balances
ton port je pense l'italie l'italie
d'alitalia
l'italien a les québécois québécois
d'aller à moi je pense qu'il n'existe
pas italien et vous aussi par le pen a
lancé aussi italien j'ai quoi mais j'ai
su sud que la france ses collègues et
répète le québec ckoi au québec ccc
québec change souvent
d'autre part à ce mouvement la grève
d'hier tout autre chose à agir avec
québec hockey est ce parce que la reine
des bonnes réponses qu'est ce que vous
dites je n'ai jamais copié se réalise
pas ce qu'elle nie
ex-aequo dans la quebec quebec quebec
italie l'italie est un pas dans la bonne
réponse se sait en france non je rigole
c'est au québec qu'on sait que c'est
certainement aussi tout simplement sexy
vous comprendrez micro c'est 40 sous les
2 stars ça n'existe pas c'est trop
sexiste examen de conscience autour de
la table d'accord je prêt au juge ou au
psychiatre
c'est tout ça dit la vérité ou aussi de
le faire
m est ce que vous avez et et ce peu
importe si vous êtes une femme et vous
pensez que vous êtes passé pas dans
votre nature de d'être vous avez pas
comme les hommes 7
cette propension à aux agressions pas ce
que pense le bouc tony ça non mais je
connais des femmes
c'est très théoriques ont à faire homme
ou femme peu importe
avez vous revu repensé dans votre esprit
et vous comportement vous auriez
peut-être été trop loin dans votre vie
avec une autre personne peut être
quelque chose à vous reprocher ce
mouvement me to vous at il apporté à
vous questionner personnellement sur vos
propres actions fait le tour des tables
je peux me donner des détails mais sur
mes actions personnelles
non moi je me suis prêt je me suis posé
des questions sur mes vécu que je
n'avais pas analysé auparavant vu des
idées des choses qui se sont produites à
16.6 jamais répertorié quelques essais
lequel que ce événement dans ma vie
personnelle que je n'avais pas catalogué
que je n'avais pas caractérisée de cette
manière là donc à ce niveau là ça m'a
aidé j'adore réponse et on n'a pas
besoin d'être plus personnel que ça on a
tout compris c'est fantastique
et puis et chantal de votre côté vais
vous dû revoir les choses oui oui oui en
ce qui concerne peut-être mais
action quand j'étais plus jeune j'avais
tendance à être un peu plus colérique
donc je répondais souvent du tic au tac
et je crois que c'est quelque chose que
je m'efforce de corriger au fil des ans
parce que je trouve que des fois on
pousse un peu trop loin et on peut faire
mal à l'autre et moi je post roll et les
farces je sais alors ce show j'ai passé
mon ma façon de faire
très sérieux maintenant j'en ai fait des
farces mais quand je fais des phases qui
y voir je pense que c'est très rare
pense que vous vous regardez pas de ces
faits diffère des voix non non j'ai pas
mais quand je fais des grands défense me
voir je connais très bien la personne et
je fais en général avec une seule
personne et c'est c'est très rare c'est
arrivé comme deux fois au bureau
j'alerte les gens disent ah ça parce que
j'ai toujours jeudi fallait rire un peu
quand même
alors ça me c'est ce qui sera remis en
cause un peu ma ma compréhension de tout
ce qui aidera galanterie cas je me suis
dit ah tiens fort il faut faire
attention peut-être que ce qui est
normal pour toi ne l'est pas pour
d'autres c'est plutôt ça va et puis j'ai
pensé oh aux garçons qui grandissent il
faut qu'il soit dans dans cette logique
c'est vraiment c'est plutôt que ça qui
me préoccupe moi je suis je pense que je
suis à un âge sage maintenant je
comprends un peu les gens c'est un peu
peur surtout pour les garçons formés mes
deux garçons donc pas vraiment je suis
sauvé dégage sans un gros problème
[Rires]
mais généralement ils sont dans un
milieu ça ils sont dans un effet
d'entraînement généralement donc il faut
essayer de contrer ça c'est parce que
quand on est ensemble avec eux on peut
leur parler mais quand ils sont en gros
place ça de fait un peu problématique
viendra vous avez des grands enfants
vous oui s disons que ces mouvements là
et ça a réveillé des choses damois de
chez moi et j'ai comme je suis devenu
plus impatientes quand j'entends des
blagues sexistes ou que j'entends des
mots déplacés envers les femmes
je le dis tout de suite maintenant avant
c'était comme bon il faut il faut lé
principal et ses protections tollet mais
là je suis devenu impatient d'accord
alors je laisse plus passer des choses
quand je les entends où je les vois très
bien avec large avec les années on
découvre de plus en plus ce qui est
important pour tous qu'il y ait des
choses qu'on fait la part des choses
inutiles qu'on veut plus bas et les
joueurs importants et marie-claude ben
évidemment oui moi aussi ça m'a
simplement rendu plus consciente des
interactions en train de femmes ou même
vingt mamans glace à ma fête
je ne peux pas dire que j'ai pas eu à
changer les comportements
mais je dois admettre aussi que chaque
fois quelqu'un genre de grosse nouvelle
par rapport à ce thème là ça me perturbe
beaucoup aussi probablement pour les
mêmes raisons que que paloma et puis
surtout quand tu te remets dans une
salle de nouvelles
c'est vraiment là que tout arrive puis
des fois sarah saga dure des jours et
des jours là ça sent ceci dit s'il sait
des choses
2 pour un dernier petit tonique qu'avant
torturent et tuent leur donne toi
stéphane est ce que ça t'a fait en effet
oui je faisais partie parce que les
gestes que j'ai posé ma c'est au niveau
de l'humour du très rarement ce que je
pense que penser que je ne fais pas du
tout mais je meurs tu veux suis dit est
ce que j'ai dit des choses qui auraient
pu tomber dans une mauvaise oreille
alors que s'étaient adressés à léona et
non pense pas mais je jeu j'en fais plus
beaucoup de farce j'annonce j'allonge
annonce avant dé faire beaucoup la
correction est important de poids
correct j'ai pas comme je faisais plus
facile
il y aura toujours de la place pour
l'humour dans nos vies d'humour non
politiquement car est important faut
laisser sortir de l'échec pour faire des
bons articles de presse pilier savoir où
on est dans une surface et serge après
sa très jeune dans la vingtaine en
faisant des entrevues avec des gens que
j'aimais pas trop haut des politiciens
enfin c'est pourquoi tu les aimes pas
bien sûr ça va être réglé en entrevue
avec eux ça va aller très mal elle
entrerait que je peux le président
américain mais j'en ai fait une pub à
bon compte histoire je vais pas nommer
le président ni l'année dernière je on
est près d'accord alors je pense qu'on
va gagner
oui en fait le tour de la table ça vous
convient vous avez points jusqu'à
maintenant alors oui je connais le
président le président en question
oui mais non combien de points vous a vu
jusqu'à maintenant mais j'ai juste
gagner juste dit une fois vous tout
j'avais bien travaillé cinq ans 4,30 à
6,30 c'est foutu c'est fou s'attaque
cette école je suis resté sur les talons
aura présidé au numéro 4 pour la
question on appuie d'une vidéo ça doit
être ça va aider les images ça est
toujours est-ce que vous reconnaissez
cet homme il va falloir faire une pause
durant la vidéo a mené un accord ce que
reconnaissait cet homme qui suit je vous
reconnais c'est cet homme
dites-moi d'hommes qui est cet homme et
c'est un acteur ou pensé lui en deux
premiers n'ont cessé de 15 ans garçons
je pense ou deux sur son dos ben oui
plusieurs inconnues je propose on fait
une pause oui une partie des accusations
ont dirigé des choses alors la question
quelle est la grande actrice je sais que
vous suivez pas les potins aussi quelle
est la grande agglo disent écoutez la
cette occasion cds de minutes avant que
britanniques quelle grande actrice s'est
récemment porté à la défense de charisme
et citadine denève le qualifiant de bons
amis elle a dénoncé demi tour des choix
non ho kelly l'actrice anglaise on va
vous aider un peu par emma thompson pour
qu'on ait malcomson non je sais pas non
non je n'ai je réponds pas aux tendons
du nom je sais pas sa défense personnes
voulaient choix que j'ai fait ce bond
un indice quelle grande actrice
britannique s'est porté à la défense de
kevin speccy récemment elle a joué le
rôle d'un james bond à l'abri la femme
âgée
la femme âgée non je voulais bien haut
mais peut-être vous avez dit chez les
mézinais qui n'ont rien 70 ans est là qu
est ce que vous savez ces quartiers de
londres l'a dit oui à côté d'un disney
[Musique]
bon j'ai pas dire non de cinquante
points ça vous donne 50 points aura
vraiment de mémoire française comme
catherine deneuve et d'autres non
oui non sens l'ouïe